[Music]
i'm gonna read your original post if you
don't mind
i usually don't post on here but back in
2007 dan schneider hosted an audition
event for child actors where you had to
show up barefoot and film your audition
putting your feet to the camera talking
about how much you loved being without
shoes i'd do anything now to find that
audition call listing not what i uh
because it's the whole reason why i'm
not in the industry anymore my mom was
in charge pulled me out telling me that
is sick and people like him should be
exposed so obviously
i was like hey you mind coming on the
show because we're sort of uh this is
our thing right now so in 1997 i was
discovered in a mall
um and um
basically
we would go on auditions just to
different places and eventually i got a
manager and an agent um who would send
me on audition calls for you know
meaning like little things like
commercials and everything and then
as i started growing in my career
in 2007 my agent contacted me and my
family about um possibly getting a good
nickelodeon gig um
i personally at the time i watched a ton
of nickelodeon and i was very immersed
in that lifestyle so i wanted to
pursue it my mom had some and she was my
manager at the time she had some you
know reservations about it she didn't
really want me um being exposed like
that
especially because in the um
audition call listing they did mention
like you know wear something cute like
wear spaghetti straps or a skirt or you
know whatever and my mom when she told
me later on that whenever she saw things
like that she thought that it was a
little uncomfortable for people to be
telling kids what to wear how old were
you at the time so
um this was i was probably around 15 at
15 14 years old
okay go ahead um and um
we
i beca and i was actually considered
older at the time for what they were
looking for um so in 2007 my agent
called about the nickelodeon show it was
for zoe 101 but because that show i
think was getting canceled at the time
they were looking just for anything and
then dan schneider's next show was
icarly so they were looking for you know
extras or possibly like a lead type of
role so of course my agent jumped on
that opportunity and we
flew out to la
for this audition
and when we got there it was
a bunch of kids probably like 200 kids
um and then these random agents hand
selected specific kids that they liked
or you know showed some charisma
and then um once about 40 kids were
selected we were then told
to take off our shoes and that we were
each going to go into a room to show the
producer who is dan schneider
the tapes to see who we would want on
the show
and um of course you know we always ask
like oh what do we have to do like what
would you like us to be doing once we're
in there and
um
my agent told me he you know he's like
it's going to be like
he's like you got to just take off your
shoes just like run around in front of
the camera you know talk about how much
you love being barefoot and at the time
even you know it was like
okay that's weird but i didn't think
anything of it because i was still young
right and then when i saw other kids
doing it like their parents were like
take your shoes off like we're going in
like this is it this is your thing you
know it was all the kids that were
wearing like the short shorts like the
you know spaghetti strap tank tops you
know things that were a little more open
and less reserved
um
and then once we um got into the last
room before my audition happened my mom
kind of looked around and was like this
is wrong
um
there's just something really wrong
about this and i at the time i was
really upset because i wanted to do this
and
the new cast started with a two-week
comedy boot camp that schneider held
with the help of the team that included
the show's dialogue coach brian peck
were the parents there i'd love to know
for two weeks unlikely right if you were
to you would say unlikely right
that's
that that that's
that's the set i mean by the way you can
look this up again it's in the la times
just search for groom to be all that
2002 article
it was uh written by uh michael lewis
lucas sorry this was the la times 2002
yeah in the summer so that means the
convicted child predator we're not
talking about uh diddle the kid one time
ryan peck a
from what from what it appears to be a
prolific
sexual predator
worked on set
ran a ran comedy boot camps for children
with none other than prolific
nickelodeon producer dan schneider in
2015 brian peck the same one from this
article uh he's convicted of sexually
abusing nickelodeon's child star is
still working with underage kids
nickelodeon child star this article says
him and schneider are running boot camps
all right listen that doesn't mean
there's guilt by association but again
if you add this to all the other stuff
smoke there's fire at some point right
yeah at least enough for someone to look
into it we read a story that they had
these boot camps before
do are the kids left alone at any point
with just the producers or or anything
like that
um there was a place in california i
think it was oakland i'm not really sure
about the um
name exactly but it was in la and it was
close to
um
like where the managers and agents
offices are so that you can get to your
auditions really quickly
um so what would happen is that your
parents would send you to sort of like
this camp
and
you would
be separate from your parents and the
parents would be going through their own
seminar basically telling them like oh
and just how to be i guess and then for
the kids it was basic acting classes
and
it was an opportunity for the kids to
get discovered and
interestingly enough most of the kids
got discovered by the pool
jesus christ
by the so the place had a pool
there was a they had a pool they had
like tennis courts and i believe like it
was like megan fox and um other
female and hillary duff was another one
who got discovered there at the pool
and they would push you to
do pool activities because they said
that's where you you have the highest
chance of getting discovered
what was the age range of of the people
that went to these uh at these camps
um the age ranges the ones that i was
familiar with are ages 13 to 22.
okay so they have 13 year olds telling
them to stand by the pool meanwhile
their parents are at some [ __ ]
seminar that the people basically you're
here we're going to put your parents in
the room and we know they're busy for an
hour right you know what i mean like
like hey don't you go outside i have
this seminar and i'll take your kids to
the pool do you understand how freaking
strange that sounds like in the family i
grew up in oh my god
like do you understand my mom like my
mom you know uh she indulged a couple of
my stupid impulses
sure yeah you'd be president someday
you'd be an actor whatever my mom
dragged me around with some dumb things
and indulged my little dreams but if
some guy was like hey
i'm gonna bring little mikey out to the
pool why don't you go take this seminar
my mom would be like no
no that's i'm you're not taking my child
to a pool
weirdo
it was more of the enticement of the
parents can meet the agents while the
kids do
whatever with strangers and a lot it's
not like the people that they left us
with were like certified in anything or
anything
and it keeps happening and there's more
creepy things and then then you hear
like you know when these they paid off
ndas get signed and people don't want to
complain because there's a stigma behind
it and they think they're afraid that if
let's go ahead
it's a lot of the time it's the money or
it's
you know a lot of these children actors
and actresses this is all they know
so
when a threat like if you don't do
something like this you're not going to
get any calls anymore and it does happen
and you see it happening to your fellow
actors and actresses who you know might
have missed the call or whatever and i
have to say even after the um
dan schneider audition
after my mom wrote in to
my agent at the time and said to her
this was wrong and
my daughter's not going to be parading
around a camera for just anybody to see
i need to know the names of the people
who the auditions are going to
after my mom you know sent that into my
agent she
pretty much blacklisted me and stopped
calling and
um
i wouldn't you know and i would call
other agents to be like maybe they would
have something for me and they would
know her and they would also just be
like no that's okay and for a while you
know obviously because i was a kid i was
like oh my god it was me but as i got
older i was like oh so because i didn't
do what they wanted to do and because we
thought it was a little weird
they
you know they cut me off i got one
question and and this one dave martel
from mad american network he'll love me
for asking this one you said you get a
lot of weird casting sheets and requests
and stuff they ever do bows in the hair
they do what they ever ask for bows in
the hair is that ever a thing
um when you're younger um
a lot of the times or back when in my
time of being a child after actress um
we i was a pageant girl before i was an
actress
and
the more stuff you had in the hair
it was told to you the more you'd get
noticed so
in reality in i guess
so if you did have bows in your hair
you'd probably get noticed a lot more
oh so i and then i have one i have
another question too regarding like your
mom and you know obviously obviously you
guys had a rough day or two i'm sure
back at home and pro you probably hated
her guts but uh you guys uh you guys
pretty tight now i mean obviously you
appreciate her in retrospect being a
little older i would assume
for a long time i was kind of resenting
like my mom when i would see like other
people who are getting famous for like
no reason kind of thing
and then i once like the later you know
like the 2010 came around and i was
seeing
what
fame does to people just from an outside
view
you know she saw that picture she saw
that picture of amanda bynes at the mall
and was like jesus christ
i'm gonna take you out for coffee mom
we're gonna have a good time
i saw some you know a lot of just let
you know it was you know in what i
watched was like lindsay lohan and like
britney spears completely crumble in
front of the public eye
in the back of my head i was like wow
how far would i have gotten pushed to be
successful
and
you know thank god my mom she saw me
because who knows what kind of
life i would have had otherwise yeah
this girl this girl saw jamie lynn
spears
being a single mom at 17 and she was
like hey you know what mom i bought you
a spa package
why don't we go out get a massage
it's not appropriate just the over
sexualization that has been going on
with children is just not
it's it's not helping anybody and it's
just fueling these sick people in the
world yeah because in our opinion for
every weinstein you see it's like they
start grooming them from when they're
child actors i mean you know and that's
where it starts you know and then by the
time yeah by the time they're up there
you know why weinstein is more of the
same it's oh i'm this is what i did to
get on all that so this is what i have
to do to get an oscar
you know right you're just conditioning
people for abuse and then they get older
they're just more they're more passive
and then and then they're more willing
to subject their kids to the abuse
because it's been normalized to them at
this point that's why you see this stuff
you see these actresses
now their kids are acting and stuff and
you don't think that they know what's
going on come on